boa tarde a todos o brasil está aqui com
vocês
e hoje o que o fim falar pra vocês aqui
é um pouco da minha trajetória acadêmica
desafios e conquistas a essa palestra
surgiu essa conversa que eu tenho você
exatamente questionando as leis que hoje
existe tanto a nível mundial enquanto a
nível de brasil que falam de igualdade
de condições em termos de estudo inteiro
de trabalho
então apenas votar o orçamento agetop é
pra vocês verem que entre as faces ea
realidade existe uma lacuna muito grande
a visão aos sete anos de idade
sobre o grande do sul cachoeira do sul e
ainda não tinha nenhuma escola pessoas
deficientes também prendeu um cego da
cidade
portanto material em praia naquela época
era inexistente e nessa idéia de
acessibilidade e inclusão coisa que nem
de pensar quando levava 14 anos
contudo o ensino fundamental eu pensei
em porto alegre uma vez de semana o
centro praia onde foi atendido e algum
material para mim é suprido época havia
apenas a máquina de escrever em braille
que é praticamente manual
então a produção bibliográfica que ela
feita é uma pena porque era um instituto
em terreno uma relação pública pequena e
muitos alunos contanto que tinha o passe
do passe de tudo
cimed também portanto eu te dizer bonito
aaaah nebulização alguém dia para mim os
textos em ações a tal da família
organizava e começou a surgir as
dificuldades
somente na área da matemática química
física ou seja as áreas abstratas
aí vejo estipular que novamente maior op
material de memorizar os principais
textos mais importantes eu menti pra mim
estudar
aí eu fui aprovado na universidade
federal do rio grande do sul ea seca que
a dificuldade em se concentrar bastante
evidentes por exemplo era um certo ranço
instituto diárias
naquela época aqui no brasil existe a
ações de partituras pra diana um hino à
fundação
antigamente não tinha em uma partitura
no dia em que copiar todas elas
normalmente a pesquisa a harmonia
contraponto análise musical existente
eu tinha que estudar com colegas e nesse
sentido na um inteiro dos professores me
ajudar pediu aos colegas foi um lance
impressionante
depois disso eu fui pra califórnia sul
da califórnia e suor noturno o autismo
obviamente eu era o único 100 muito boa
mas novamente eu
o problema a bibliografia básica
o roubo fable iii a moça conhece esses
jogos são importantíssimos e novamente
ela tinha que preparar bem material
e aí que surgiu a idéia nessa época de
conversar com a computação um leitor de
tela
nessa época que foi o início de 2000 só
final de janeiro eram extremamente
visual o software de música tentados
mídias digitais
o software que contar com o apoio da
judite sousa que foram me ajudando
mas aí começou a pesquisa na computação
eu fui um softwares como kiko que é
juntamente com 11
o dia ou fazer algumas aplicações admite
que não tinha uma independência e
autonomia para fazer todas as análises a
corrigir precisava de alguém mais ou
menos já começou aí a idéia de um poder
transcrever partituras
informou wagner é um pouco melhor ano
quando entrei no pdt em etnomusicologia
desvirtuam gosto social que a marca
bastante teórica na área específica 2011
indicado ou seja puramente musical é
bastante teórico
a bibliografia básica mim para uso não
existia então novamente mais começou
mais uma luta pra postar esse material
foi aí que eu tive várias reuniões com
retorne à coordenadoria aí foi reativado
da laboratório de exibida tá subir
laboratório de acessibilidade da
universidade de washington
e aí que começamos a lançar com o as
para digitalizar os livros para o leitor
de tela lê pra mim mas por exemplo a
música ela não é só ser digitalizada e
leitão de carvalho caminho ela tem que
passar por todo o processo de
administração tem que passar vários
programas a partir daí passar praia e
nesse processo todo existe bastante -
quando cheguei aqui não encanta e quim
e foi num coque se via o programa de
incentivo aos receptores que eu comecei
com um projeto de uma tecnologia nave ou
não para pessoas deficientes visuais
porque na califórnia entre os estudos
ele fez um uso do metodológico de como o
professor
a vidente ia passar pra mim as idéias do
violão a detenta parte tentativa que
queira não a parte de peso
11 ela utiliza muito a visão sem contar
as partidas
e aí eu for me e comecei a falar dessa
metodologia santo com o professor fábio
scarano é depois com resina
acessibilidade computacional a
transcrição de algumas partituras e eu
concluir pelo primeiro posto ao longo de
2014 e 2015
tive o prazer de conhecer o muitas
idéias ea partir daí comecei o meu
segundo o autor adu que é fazendo
exclusivamente da computação há pouco o
nome do meu projeto o nosso projeto é a
acessibilidade visual a se a nintendo
atividade em computacionais através de
conteúdos computacionais e não teve ou
não se eu venho atuando também na
faculdade de educação musical e
orientando alunos e ao formamos
repetitivos um culto disse faz alguns
alunos que ele cita se beneficia
interdisciplinaridade e comunicação de
computação artística que nós estamos
investigando várias a aplicações através
da computação que eu posso criar um
software não somente da transcrição de
partituras mas também como performance
ou seja para trabalhar com estúdio para
gravações arranjo
uma coisa que eu sempre com 58 entre os
quais o dano da que participa rêbelo no
que estamos fazendo nos outdoors nesse
sentido
bom o que eu falei para vocês aqui a não
foi com a visão e ativista de um juízo
onde me encontrar de que a eu consegui
chegar até aqui mas eu quis mostrar a
vocês as dificuldades que ainda existe
hoje em dia dentro da nossa realidade
por exemplo se hoje dia no computador a
uma pessoa deficiente visual ela tem se
comparada com uma pessoa com visão 10% e
talvez de acesso do que como eu posso
dizer com relação à sua pessoa pra ler
uma partitura do ano o computador é
muito fácil uma pessoa que tinha apenas
que a partir dali está pronto não tem
que passar por um processo de adaptação
de softwares para chegar ao resultado
final
a imagem essas coisas não é possível
então nós estamos trabalhando exatamente
nesse sentido visão computacional a
música gestual ea geração só agora
através de métodos comuns tanto como
nacionais
então a minha pergunta pra vocês é o
seguinte dentro das leis apregoou que de
todos os tempos os direitos de igualdade
a aí pede pra vocês
se nós entrarmos dentro de uma
universidade com dentro de um a escola
qualquer o material básico para nós a
usarmos seja qual o fórum existe
material base então não determinar a
outra coisa que a gente estudando o
texto todo o ano
a cidade também não existe esse material
básico para que possa acompanhar em
condições de igualdade os outros alunos
então essas reflexões que eu gostaria de
deixar vocês mas para isso como uma
mensagem gostaria sim pra vocês que nós
o caso teu dela mas eu vou colocando
todas as pessoas deficientes em especial
de pessoas ou instituições
não podemos ficar parados esperando que
as coisas aconteçam nós temos que ser
toda a conversa tão só então ter
acessibilidade e durante esses anos
todos e entrou
aquilo que lhe expressar minha gratidão
a todas as pessoas que têm me ajudado e
ajudado desde o início desde os estados
unidos e aqui especialmente onde eu não
teria chegado até aqui se não fosse pela
ajuda que estas pessoas como agora eu
não tenho meus alunos do centro de todas
as pessoas moratória de acessibilidade e
acho que é isso que eu queria falar pra
vocês eu queria ter sido muito
descobrisse a todos